while the world waits to see that
surveillance memo president Trump
brought his 2018 playbook to Republican
lawmakers still perhaps a bit shaken up
after yesterday's train accident and he
did it without commenting on the fine
said document chief White House
correspondent John Roberts tells us what
happened today from the north longer
than John Brad could evening you'll
remember at the State of the Union
address on Tuesday night President Trump
was caught on an open mic telling a
Republican member 100 percent he would
release the memo
the president has read the contents of
the memo and were told is ready to
release it but the President himself is
playing his cards close to his vest
arriving back at the White House from
the Republican retreat in West Virginia
president Trump ignored questions about
the FISA memo as he had when he was
leaving this morning the president
wanted to keep the focus on his 2018
agenda we will be demonstrating that we
are very very serious top of the list
daca border security and immigration
reform
president Trump blasting Democrats for
quote doing nothing about daca revealing
his offer of a path to citizenship for
1.8 million dreamers was a test for
Democrats I wanted to see whether or not
they were interested in approving that
because if they don't approve something
within that sphere that means very
simply that they not looking to approve
it at all and in a new twist president
Trump said by the way don't call them
dreamers some people call it dreamers
it's not dreamers don't fall into that
trap
we have dreamers in this country too you
can't forget our dreamers Democrats have
nothing kind to say about the
President's agenda Nancy Pelosi calling
the State of the Union address it quote
performance devoid of any serious policy
ideas President Trump fired back here's
a serious idea how about bonuses for
workers from the tax cut with these
corporations giving tremendous bonuses
to everybody that Nancy Pelosi called
crumbs that was a bed that could be like
deplorable does that make sense
deplorable and crumbs to which the
minority leaders office replied what's
deplorable is Republicans desperate
effort to hide the multi-billion dollar
corporate windfalls of the GOP tax scam
behind a handful of meager one-time
bonuses and that wasn't the only dust-up
between the White House and Democrats
earlier at the Republican retreat vice
president Mike Pence took a coal shovel
to West Virginia Senator Joe Manchin Joe
voted no to give working families more
of your hard earned money
Joe voted no on tax cuts for job
creators Joe is just gonna keep voting
against West Virginia Manchin didn't
like that one bit
tweeting back Mike Pence talks a good
game as far as bipartisanship but I met
with their team 21 times to make tax
cuts larger and permanent for the middle
class not big businesses and
millionaires they decided to be strictly
partisan instead of helping the middle
class West Virginians for his part the
president singled out Democrats who sat
on their hands at the State of the Union
refusing to applaud even when he noted a
historically low unemployment rate for
African Americans and when I made that
statement the other night there was zero
movement from the Democrats which tells
you perhaps they'd rather see us not do
well than see our country do great and
that's not good that's not good
Fox News is told tonight that a deal on
daca remains elusive and that there may
not be anything in place by the time the
government runs out of money next
Thursday in fact legislative text on the
president's immigration proposal may not
be available until at least February the
9th which means negotiators are going to
start to feel the heat from that looming
March 5th deadline to do something to
fix daca right
you know John we're getting word that
the president's going to head to Ohio to
talk about taxes on Monday is there a
sense that it's going to be easy to get
a continuing resolution by February 8th
I'm told that there won't be any problem
getting the continuing resolution that
the Democrats have no appetite to shut
the government down again what will be
difficult is getting a deal on the
budget caps because I'm being told by
sources here at the White House that the
Democrats are holding fast that there
needs to be an agreement on daca before
they'll tackle the budget caps so a
continuing resolution is one thing a
budget deals quite another Brett exactly
John Roberts live in the North Lawn John
thanks